l'insuline est une association qui
fêtera ses dix ans l'année prochaine et
qui a été créée donc avec des patients
et des soignants
l'idée étant de mixer 7,7 cette
communauté insulaire est une association
qui travaille sur l'ensemble du de la
région le département du bas-rhin et
département du haut rhin et qui a
l'objectif premier c'est de vulgariser à
nouveau traitement qui hélas une
thérapie fonctionnel et qui permet donc
aux patients diabétiques et bien doser
sa dose d'insuline en fonction de son
alimentation et non pas l'inversé de
s'alimenter en fonction de la dose
d'insuline qui s'est injecté or au
préalable nous sommes une association
qui regroupe une centaine de morts une
association qui organise des groupes de
parole pour permettre aux patients
diabétiques d'échanger sur leurs
pratiques
une association qui organise des
conférences mais aussi une association
et c'est relativement peu fréquent et
associe systématiquement la famille du
patient puisque le diabète est une
maladie
malheureusement que l'on partage et il
est important que toutes les personnes
qui entourent le patient soit informé de
ce qu'est le diabète en réalité le
diabète est aujourd'hui une véritable
pandémie qui concerne l'ensemble des
pays du monde et prévisions en matière
de diabète sont régulièrement ajustées
elles ne sont pas ajustés à la baisse
elles sont ajustés à la hausse c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous paraît
extrêmement important que nous puissions
sensibiliser la population à des
contrôles réguliers de glycémie qui
permettent le cas échéant de détecter la
présence de diabète et d'entamer un
traitement plus la glycémie et traiter
tous plus le diabète est traitée tôt
plus les risques de complications ce mou
sont moins importants c'est une
sensibilisation qui concerne l'ensemble
des personnes sur ce que devrait être
notre hygiène de vie à savoir une
hygiène alimentaire à savoir la notion
d'exercice physique pour permettre de
prendre en charge ses traits
l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de
rencontrer des patients diabétiques les
patients diabétiques qui sont un peu
isolés dans leur maladie car il faut
savoir que le diabète est une maladie
qui très fréquemment isole les personnes
peut le cas échéant les conduire à la
dépression le patient diabétique n'est
pas une personne handicapée
c'est une personne qui doit suivre
scrupuleusement un traitement et qui si
elle suit scrupuleusement ce traitement
est bien toutes les chances de vivre
avec sa maladie
au même titre que n'importe quelle
personne via avec sa réalité quotidienne
la meilleure façon de savoir c'est
effectivement de procéder à des
contrôles de glycémie le contrôle de
glycémie peut-être bien évidemment fait
chez le médecin traitant comme le
contrôle de glycémie peut être faite
chez un pharmacien aujourd'hui un peu
partout en france ils sont régulièrement
effectués soit à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale du diabète qui est le
14 novembre soit autour de cette journée
est le conseil que je pourrais me
permettre de donner c'est que toute
personne puisse contrôler sa glycémie au
moins une fois par an ce n'est pas un
acte très compliqué ça dure quelques
secondes et ça permet de se situer à
partir de évidemment des résultats
obtenus
la personne sera orienté vers un
professionnel de santé ou tout
simplement la personne sera revue
l'année suivante la journée de
sensibilisation au diabète qui a été
organisée en étroit partenariat avec le
conseil départemental regroupe sert des
associations dont c'est le domaine
d'action mais aussi d'autres
associations qui travaillent dans des
maladies qui sont des maladies connexes
au diabète et je pense que l'intérêt
c'est de présenter aux patients cet
éventail mais aussi pour l'avenir
d'organiser d'autres manifestations qui
pourront regrouper tous les acteurs